c'est vrai que se mettre une carte dans
le cul pour certains c'est une
provocation mais pour moi c'est juste un
gars
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Louis bonsoir vous êtes né à Paris
en 1954 parallèlement des études
d'architecture vous jouez dans des
groupes de rock vous voyagez en Afrique
en Amérique du Sud en Asie en 1986 la
musique devient votre activité
principale et vous cessez de jouer avec
des groupes pour créer seul des chansons
paroles très crues vous faites sur scène
des comédies musicales trash des opéras
porno des disques des films vous avez de
nombreux procès vous écrivez dans des
revues comme hermaphrodite cancer bordel
ça plaît
vous faites un texte plus long qui est
publié qui s'appelle viva la merda puis
vous rencontrer Raphaël sort un chez
Fayard vous publiez grand-père un
bouquin assez impressionnant alors moi
je les ai connu il y a 10 ans à l'époque
de Paris dernière
performeur underground super gore au
foyer des horreurs sur scène même moi
j'étais choquée et aujourd'hui je vous
retrouve en écrivain
selinha pasolinia bukowskia et votre
livre est vraiment étonnant vraiment un
style quoi alors le pitch et la vie de
votre grand-père qui s'appelle garni que
Sarkissian arménien plongée dans toutes
les barbaries du 20e siècle
quand on vous demande c'est une
autobiographie vous dites
qu'effectivement vous avez un grand-père
s'appelait garni qui était immigré
arménien victime de pogrom et puis il y
a quatre mots comme ça qui sont cosaque
légionnaires bagnards et collabo et ces
quatre mots ont finalement stimuler
votre imagination
et vous ont amené à écrire ce livre
désespéré épique et décapant voilà
vous pouvez nous en lire un bout là
en fait bon mon grand-père après avoir
fait Kozak légionnaires etc il a été
blessé à la guerre et ils l'ont lâché en
France
et il avait pas de papier pas de travail
il savait que tu es c'est un type qui
avait fait que massacrer à travers toute
la terre donc ça c'est dans les années
30 il rencontre ma grand-mère dans le
métro Paris il a séduit avec sa
moustache à la
exotique là et donc ma grand-mère tombe
amoureuse et veut le présenter à ses
parents mais évidemment ça fait un peu
bug parce que ses parents ça a pas bien
de banlieue et lui il arrive arménien
Kozak et donc c'est il arrive dans le
pavillon il sait pas mettre les patins
il arrête pas de faire des gaffes sur
gaffe
servez-vous le poulet est prêt tout ça
il prend le poulet
il crache les eaux dans le plat et alors
voilà les lectures commencent et là je
mets les lunettes du prophète pour
assurer
donc il crache les eaux dans le plat
comme ça
mais c'est dégoûtant la mer au quête
dans sa serviette le père explose eh
mais tu nous en amener beaucoup comme ça
des [__] moi pas de Bonnie au moins
Arménie répond le fiancé bourré c'est le
face à face des mâles devant les
femelles le père descend son verre de
rouge le fiancé descend son verre de
rouge et le jette en arrière à la russe
bam dans la vitrine au bibelots la
Sainte Vierge de Lourdes explose et fous
de la neige partout tout le monde est
couvert de flocons et d'éclats de verre
une seconde de calme avant l'orgasme
ma Sainte Vierge de Lourdes que maman
m'avait offerte eh mais c'est que va
tout nous bousiller ce bico s'ennuie mon
joueur le perchobe son fusil entre la
tête de serre et le saucisson la vieille
se saute dans la cuisine pour protéger
le chat
toi la fiancée retient le fiancé qui
veut tout [__]
quoi mon chéri je t'en prie calme-toi le
père drague son fusil sur les couilles
de la montre sa fille non papa non pas
les couilles le fiancé chope le canon du
fusil ou quoi toi moi cosaque bousculade
boum boum boum le coupable le calibre 12
pète mais les plombs ratent le
fiançailles [__] ils traversent la
cage du canari déchiqueté en plein cucul
ok bon c'est à cause de quand même il
comprend qu'il est en face de lui un
calibre 12 alors il se casse le fiancé
bord traite par la fenêtre la fiancée
amoureuse de lui pleure du sang mais
elle l'aime tellement qu'elle s'accroche
à lui il piétine les rosiers et fuient
vers la gare le père hurle au milieu de
ses études avec son fusil jamais tu
m'entends reviens jamais
la fiancée jolie heureuse pimpante vous
les présenter son prince charmant à ses
parents mais les parents sont cons et le
prince est lourd alors ça a mal tourné
évidemment
d'étrangers la séparé des vieux français
pour l'éternité
voilà
quand je disais quand je disais Céline
Bukowski je crois que j'étais pas loin
voilà alors cette écriture justement a
duré 6 semaines vous êtes enfermé dans
une cave à Saint-Denis vous avez fait
1000 pages sans orthographe sans
ponctuation et vous avez donné tout ça à
Fayard ils ont remis ça en ordre avec 38
de fièvre parce que vous êtes atteint
d'un paludisme qui résiste aux
médicaments
j'ai souvent en Guyane oui parce que bon
comme j'ai une vie dans une cave
finalement soit parce que je fais de la
musique soit de la littérature j'ai
besoin de m'isoler complètement une cave
et je fais des concerts c'est encore
dans des cases donc cette tendance ça
fait bien d'être en Guyane oh en grand
air dans la jungle loin d'Internet loin
de toi vous avez une cabane en Guyane au
milieu de la forêt amazonienne
vous avez une machette et des boîtes de
sardines
et comme vous arrivez là-bas vous avez
défricher votre votre terrain et vous
avez foutu le feu vous allez brûlé la
moitié de la Guyane ça a duré deux mois
je suis arrivé en bonne écolo les petits
singes tout ça mais bon je me fais mon
terrain mais franchement gentiment quoi
parce que là-bas les gens quand ils
foutent le feu ils foutent le feu direct
à la jungle le terrain avec du feu parce
que la jungle est humide ne peut pas
prendre feu moi évidemment j'arrive en
plein El Nino donc la Guyane est sèche
ce qui arrive tous les 1000 ans quoi et
je fous mon feu mais gentiment au milieu
de jardin la française avec précaution
non non surtout pas abîmer la forêt un
petit feu au milieu de terrain et la
nuit j'entends pas
papa tout le village dans cerclé de
flammes et c'était moi l'étranger en
plus je squatais mon terrain parce qu'en
Guyane on prend un terrain j'avais pas
acheté le terrain et donc il y a vrai il
y avait le gros titre du journal Le cœur
de la Guyane entre en feu un clandestin
sur un apathique sans destin c'était moi
quoi quand je suis reparti mais tout
penaud dans le petit UP parce qu'il faut
prendre un petit avion j'ose même plus
aller au village
quand je suis reparti je voyais toute la
forêt en flamme au loin un mois et demi
que ça crame
et alors quand je les ai connu vous
étiez vraiment donc comme je l'ai dit
vraiment hardcore et puis là j'ai
l'impression quand même que vous
découvrez une certaine spiritualité vous
dites qu'il y a deux ans à Dunkerque à
la sortie d'un show vous êtes bourré
vous êtes à poil enfin vous avez juste
des chaussettes en fait et là vous
traînez dans la zone industrielle près
d'un centre Leclerc et vous tombez sur
un calvaire avec un avec un Christ et là
d'un seul coup voilà il y a un retour à
la spiritualité qui s'opère non c'est à
dire je suis sorti la salle où je ne
fais un spectacle en juin après les
spectacles bon c'est pas que je bois
énormément mais un bizarre effet de
trans je sais pas mais entre l'alcool et
l'excitation et le spectacle je suis
complètement barré donc j'étais même à
poil il faisait super froid il gelé tout
était glacé et je vois bon c'est que des
supermarchés des zones industrielles la
salle était un Scott au milieu dans les
échangeur alors bon ça allait être des
trucs quoi et jouer cette croix qui se
dresse dans une sorte de petite jungle
je vais là-bas bon comme ça quand on est
bon on fait tous passe la grille et en
fer forgé et tout un truc moyenne un jeu
quoi je vois une source
et bon je savais que quand il y a une
source j'ai capté que c'était une source
magique ou un truc j'ai pissé dedans je
vais faire une offrande j'ai regardé ce
Christ et d'un coup franchement je
tombais à genoux mais un truc de malade
alors je sais pas du tout pratiquement
les services j'ai capté trop mais
c'était au niveau de la pitié je me suis
il fait super froid tout le monde
s'amuse là-dedans cette salle à se
défoncer tout ça ce mec à poil crucifié
personne n'en a rien à [__] ça m'a
vachement touché et maintenant j'ai
compris que c'est une religion même le
plus puissant des papes ou des rois il a
une victime sur son une victime quoi là
alors que toutes les religions présentes
des gens glorieux Bouddha en or bien
gras là où le Christ ressuscité comme
Orient et là en Europe les mecs ils
mettent le mec dans la merde ça m'a
super touché parce que moi je suis quand
même un clochard quasi
j'ai vu un mec dans la merde je suis
vraiment depuis ce jour là je
m'intéresse vachement au rituel
catholique c'est peut-être mon côté
chaud théâtral et tout ça et je
m'intéresse beaucoup catholicisme du
point de vue du rituel
vous avez raison alors vous avez pas
fini d'écrire Jean-Louis Coz vous dites
je m'enfoncerai toujours plus en
moi-même sans répit jusqu'à ce que je
trouve la sortie vous êtes vraiment
partie dans le truc quoi je pense que
j'ai monfermé dans ma cave il y a un
tunnel qui va s'ouvrir l'infini et je
vais voir qu'il y a un autre monde inter
de ma tête qui est plus grand que
l'Amazon alors on va faire une interview
à prendre ou à laisser
des adjectifs vous allez me dire si
c'est à prendre ou à laisser en ce qui
vous concerne d'accord
misogyne
j'ai peur du vagin mais j'aime la femme
néo-réac
ah oui je suis totalement rexé c'est
clair chez toi à l'envers
ni liste
oui quand je bande pas ouais raciste pas
du tout alors
dégueulasse
enfin on dit que je fais des trucs
dégueulasses mais pour moi c'est juste
la normale on est plein de merde de
toute façon
toute façon 1% du temps quoi quand je
bande c'est tout
provocateur
bon franchement je me rends pas compte
c'est vrai que se mettre une carotte
dans le cul pour certains c'est une
provocation mais pour moi c'est juste un
gars
et là pour la prochaine fois je mets la
prochaine fois je mets une boîte de
petits pois gore
non romantique génial ah oui sûrement
produit marketing très étudié il faut
demander à ça
entière
mais à force de Christ on atteint la
gloire néo beauf
en fait quand j'ai raconté l'histoire de
mon grand-père j'ai vu que derrière les
bofs des années 50 coucher de dans leur
télé il y a eu des supers héros entre
opportuniste
ouais parce que j'ai compris que mon
chaos je pouvais en faire un business
politiquement incorrect parce que je
sais pas ce que ça veut dire je suis
politisé comme mon chat c'est à dire que
le CP je m'en fous mais si la bagnole
crame je m'en fous pas parce que je me
cachais dessus pour me protéger des
chiens
dangereux
moi qu'une banque artiste de merde
ouais mais bon
cynique
non je suis pas signé
c'est une autre époque je sens vraiment
pas cette problématique je la refuse
intégrale antisocial oui carrément
gros con
ouais je suis con mais j'ai remarqué que
plus on va vers un sujet con comme les
oxyures ou le caca plus on découvre des
trucs géniaux quoi tout le monde
méprisait ça faut le reconnaître mais
moi-même je trouvais que c'était con
mais l'intelligence c'est dans la
connerie Schumann ouais à force c'est
une question d'expérience un poster
ça vous juge
alcoolique non pas du tout d'ailleurs un
demi-verre de champagne Sofiane bourré
pamelillac totalement je vois le danger
partout j'étais sûr que vous alliez
annuler l'émission
homosexuel refoulé ah oui d'accord la
preuve la carotte
elle était peut-être ratée
infréquentable
il y a des filles qui tombent amoureuse
de moi
[Applaudissements]
pour mon chat oui
petite [__] extensible et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de tube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu